can you kind of give give me like um a
little insight on like what happened
with rumble
i mean [ __ ] nothing i mean i guess he
took it personal because he thought when
the homie said something about them but
they didn't you know what i'm saying
they were just rapping like we all
rapped right right right right bars and
bars
have meanings but he thought that
meaning was for him you know i'm saying
and it wasn't so he was wrong he hit the
little [ __ ] up and they said what they
said right so and then he hit me up and
then you know what i'm saying i told him
my [ __ ] you hit me you ain't hit me at
first and then be like you know what i'm
saying like why you say that or is they
talking about me no you went straight
and went for the kill after your homies
already hit a month so i mean y'all was
talking about it and [ __ ] like why you
don't hit me up don't hit me up to
alleviate it now like it ain't it ain't
nothing so for a [ __ ] to be like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i ain't [ __ ] with y'all
if y'all [ __ ] with them type [ __ ]
i ain't so
you know what i'm saying what you
thought jewish i guess he probably
thought he was like super big dog you
know after draco dot air but this city
was that for grabs so you know what i'm
saying nobody grabbed it just said bus
like it's not our fault
so i guess [ __ ] be kind of feeling
some type of way but that ain't got
nothing to do with me